you write about being an introvert
growing up a child of immigrants I could
relate to both of those things for sure
and and then you uh talk about how you
took a class at
Stanford Business School uh that really
changed your mindset I actually
interviewed Jeff pfeffer whom I met
through you who's the Stanford professor
and the class asked okay what is the
thing you're going to do differently as
a result of this class in your career
and you wrote down I'm going to be an
extrovert at work which is a very very
big deal uh you know I have to say uh
that that's a massive deliberate Choice
do do you advise other people who are
introverts who come to you because I'm
sure a lot of people have come to you
now for career advice do you actually
say to them hey you might you might want
to actually uh take a different attack
at work
you know I wrote this article called The
Secret bias no one talks about and it's
along the lines of Susan Kane's quiet
which is we have this massive bias in
our society in American society we
really value people who speak up you
know think about who is charismatic
who's out there who we pick as our
politicians people who pick as we for
CEO you know we don't pick the person
who's quietly doing the work behind the
scenes we're picking the person who can
stand up on stage and inspire people
right or wrong
and one of the things I I had to learn
in that class at Stanford was I had to
learn that you know that yes
introversion is a state you know we
actually have a trade and ancestry for
introversion versus extroversion and
mine is like extremely introverted and
yet at the same time I treat it like
learning a language if I had to learn a
different language to be successful you
know if I if I wanted to run a division
and it was in Spain and I had to learn
Spanish I would go do it so I just treat
it as a second language it doesn't have
to be anything
translate I would list love like I just
want to understand what that world is
but I don't have to live in that world I
still dream in my native language but at
the same time I can learn a different
language if absolutely necessary to be
successful and to persuade others and I
realize you know just like you have gone
through this Evolution you know you know
you've had gotten on stage in front of
50 million people and done something
that no one who's introverted would ever
have thought to do and yet at the same
time you did it because it was a
necessity for what you hope to
accomplish in your life and the change
that you hope to make and the voice that
you want to have and this is the same
thing for me which is we can choose to
be introverted and you know say this is
who I am or we can say I'm going to
learn this new skill that's going to be
to help me connect with other people and
when you put it that way Suddenly It's
well you know it's a skill and it's
helping me connect with other people
it's not about selfishness or giving
it's actually about the opportunity to
get out of our own heads and say how can
we help others to be more comfortable
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you